movie info: XVID  640x480 25.0fps 697.9 MB
/SubEdit b.4060 (http://subedit.com.pl)/
25.000
Look Mr. Connell. I just can't aford to be without
work. I've got a mother and two kid sisters.
More Good-luck telegrams...
You know how it is. I've just got to keep on working,
see?
Sorry sister. I was sent down here to clean house. I
told you I can't use your column anymore.
I'll tell you what I'll do. I get 30 dollars a week. I'll
take 25, 20 if necessary. I'll do anything you say
It isn't the money. We're after circulation. We need
fireworks.
I can do that. I know this town inside and out. Oh,
give me a chance!
Come in, come in, come in...
Cashier's got your check. Who are these people?
Gabs, Connie, Fonygan and Chiles...
Hey sister, don't forget to get out your last column
before you pick up your check.
Big, rich slob like D.B. Norten buys the paper and 40
heads are chopped off!
- Did you get it too?
- Yeah, you too?
Oh Joe. I'm sorry darling. Why don't we tear the
building down.
Before you do ma'm, perhaps you'd better finish this
column.
Lavendar and Old Lace.
Wait Joe! Wait.
He want fireworks huh? Okay.
Here.
Below is a letter which reached my desk this morning.
It's a commentary on what we call a civilized world.
Dear Miss Mitchell. Four years ago, I'd been fired out
of my job. Since then, I haven't been able to get a
new one.
At first I was sore at the administration, because of all
the politics here, we have all this unemployment.
But in looking around, it seems the whole world is
going to pot. So in protest, I am going to commit
suicide...
...by jumping of the City Hall roof. Signed a
disgusted, American citizen, John Doe.
Editor's note, if you ask this column, the wrong people
are jumping off the roofs.
- Hey, this is the old fake-a-roo,
- Never mind that Joe, go ahead.
And it's because of all the slimy politics that we have
all this unemployment here.
There it is. There's D.B. Norten's opening attack on
the Governor.
- Why Jim, it's just a letter sent into a column.
- No, no, I can smell him, that's Norten.
- Good-morning gentlemen.
- Good-morning Governor.
- Governor, did you happen to see this in the New
Bulletin?
- Yes, I had it served with my breakfast this morning.
- Jim thinks it's D.B. Norten at work...
Of course it is.
Oh come now. That little item. D.B. Norten does
things in a much bigger way
This is his opening attack on you Governor. Take my
word for it.
Why did he buy a paper for? Why did he engage a
high-pressure editor like Connell for? '
He's in the oil business. I tell you Governor, he's after
your scalp.
All right Jim. Don't burst a blood vessel. I'll look into
it.
- Yes sir?
- Get me Spenser of the Daily Chronical please.
Yes, yes I saw it Governor. And if you ask me, that's
a phony letter.
- Why that gag has got whiskers on it. Ok I'll get the
Mayor and maybe the Chamber of Commerce to go
after them.
- Sorry the Mayor is busy on the other phone.
Yes I know Mrs. Brewster, it's a terrible reflection on
our city. I've had a dozen calls already.
- Spencer from the Chronical.
- Hold him.
Yes Mrs. Brewster. I'm listening.
I insist that this John Doe be found, and given a job at
once. If something isn't done about it, I'll call the
whole auxiliary.
Yes Spencer? Who? The Governor? Well what
about me? It's my building he's jumping off of and I'm
up for re-election too.
What are you doing? Get Connell at the Bullentin.
- He's liable to go right past my window
- Get me Connell.
- What was that?
- What?
- Out the window Something just flew by
- I didn't see anything.
Don't stand there you idiot. Go and look. Open the
window.
Oh why did he have to pick on my building? Is there
a crowd in the street?
- No sir!
- Maybe he's caught on the ledge, look again.
- I think it must have been a sea gull
- A sea gull? What's a sea gull doing around City
Hall?
- That's a bad omen, isn't it?
- Oh no sir. The sea gull is a lovely bird.
It's all right Mrs. Brewster. It was just a sea gull.
Nothing's happened yet. I'm watching. Don't worry
just leave it all to me.
Spencer, I'll call you back. Hello Connell?
This is... What are you doing? This is the Mayor.
Yes Mayor Lovitt, how many times are you going to
call me?
Got everybody out looking for him. Did you see the
blacks I'm running?
An appeal to John Doe. Think it over John. Life can
be beautiful, says Mayor.
If you need a job, apply to the editor of this paper and
so forth and so forth.
Okay Mayor. I'll let you know as soon as I have
something. What?
Well, pull down the blinds.
- I just came from Mrs. Mitchells house, and boy is
she in a bad way.
- Where is she?
- Did you know that she supports a mother and two
kids.
- What do you know about that?
Did you find her? No, her mother is awful worried
about her. When she left the house, she said she
was going on a roaring drunk!
- Go out and find her.
- Sure.
But the biggest thing I didn't tell you, is her old man is
Dr. Mitchell. You know the doc that saved my
mother's life and wouldn't take any money for it. You
remember that?
Okay boss, I'll go and look for her.
Holy smokes Commissionair, you've had 24 hours.
Okay, grab a pencil, here it is again.
About 5 foot 5, brown eyes, light chestnut hair, and a
fine of pair of legs as...
...ever walked into this office.
- Did you want to see me?
- No. I've had the whole army and navy out searching
for you because it's a game we play here everyday.
- I remember distinctly being fired.
- That's right, but you have a piece of paper that still
belongs to this paper.
- What's that?
- The letter.
- What letter?
- The letter from John Doe.
The whole town isin an uproar. We've got to find him
and the letter is the only clue.
- There is no letter.
- Then get a handwriting expert to... What?
There is no letter.
- Say that again.
- I made it up.
- You made it up?
- Yes, you said you wanted fireworks.
Don't you know there are 9 jobs waiting for this guy
22 families want to board him free.
Five women want to marry him and a man is ready to
adopt him.
- And you...
- Just called the ward boss and they said there's a
girl...
- Ann! Say why didn't you...
- Benny!
- Only one thing to do Hank. Drop the whole business
quickly
- How?
Run a story saying John Doe was in here and he was
sorry for writing the letter...
Sure. He came in here and we got him to change his
mind.
Bulletin editor saves John Doe's life. Why it's perfect.
I'll have Ned write it up.
- Oh Ned, I've got a story I want you...
- Wait a minute.
Listen you great, big, wonderful genius of a
newspaper man...
You came down here to shoot some life into this dying
paper, didn't you? Well the whole town is curious
about John Doe and just like that, you're going to bury
him.
There's enough cirrculation in that man to start an ink
shortage.
- In what man?
- John Doe.
- What John Doe?
- My John Doe! The one I made up.
Now look genius. Suppose there was a John Doe
and he walked into this ofice. What would you do?
Give him a job and forget about the whole business I
suppose huh? Not me! I'd make a deal with him.
A deal?
Sure, when you get hold of a stunt that sells papers,
you don't drop it like a hot potatoe.
Why this is good for at least a couple of months.
Why, do you know what I'd do?
Between now and let's say Christmas, when he's
going to jump, I'd run a daily starting with his
boyhood, schooling, firstjob.
Awide-eyed youngster facing a caotic world! The
problem of the average man, of all the John Doe's in
the world.
Now, then comes the drama. He meets
discouragement, he finds the world a feet of clay his
ideals crumble. So what does he do?
He decides to commit suicide and protest against the
state of civilization.
He thinks of the river but no. He has a better idea.
City Hall. But why?
Because he wants to attract attention. He wants to
get a few things off his chest, and that's the only way
he can get himself heard...
- So?
So he writes me a letter and I dig him up. He pours
out his soul to me.
And from now on we quote: I protest, by John Doe.
He protests against all the evils in the world.
The greed, the lust, the hate, the fear All of man's
inhumanities.
Arguments will start. Should he commit suicide, or
should he not? People will write in with pleading for
him. But John Doe will remain adament. On
Christmas Eve hot or cold, he goes!
See?
Very pretty indeed Miss Mitchell. But would you mind
telling me who goes on Christmas Eve?
- John Doe!
- What John Doe!?
- The one we hire for the job, you lunk-head.
- Wait a minute. Let me get this through this lame
brain of mine.
- Are you suggesting that we go out and hire someone
to say that he is going to commit suicide on Christmas
Eve?
- Now you're catching on.
- Who for example?
- Anybody, Benny will do.
- Sure... what, who me... jump of a... anytime but
Christmas.
Miss Mitchell, do me a favor. Go on out and get
married and have a lot of babies, but stay out of
newspaper business.
- Better get that story in Hank, it's getting late.
- You're suppose to be a smart guy If it was raining
100 dollar bills, you be out looking for a dime you lost
some place.
- Holy smokes. Wasting my time, listening to this mad
woman.
- Look Chief at what the Chronical is writing on John
Doe.
Why the no good! John Doe story amature
journalism.
It's probably phony and it's a wonder that anyone is
taking it seriously. What do you think of those guys?
That's fine! Now fall right into their laps. Go ahead.
Say John Doe walked in and called the whole thing
off. You know what that's going to sound like on top
of this.
- That's all.
- All right.
- Amature journalism huh? Why those bunch of
sophomores, I can teach them more...
- Hey boss, get a load of this.
- What?
- Look.
- What do they want?
- They all say they wrote the John Doe letter.
- Oh, they all wrote the letter?
- Tell them all to wait.
Mr. Connell, one of those men is your John Doe.
They're desparate and will do anything for a cup of
coffee. Pick one out and you can make the Chronical
eat their words.
- I'm beginning to like this.
- If you ask me Hank, your beginning to play around
with dynomite.
No, no, no, the gal's right. Can't let the Chronicel get
the laugh on us. We've got to produce a John Doe
now. Amature journalism!!
- I'll show those guys.
- Sure, and there's no reason for them to find out the
truth, because naturally I won't say anything.
- Kay sister, you'll get yourjob back
- Plus a bonus.
- What bonus?
- Oh the bonus of 1000 dollars that the Chronicel was
going to pay me for this little document.
- You'll see it says, I Miss Mitchell,
- do hereby certify that the John Doe letter was
created by me... I can read, I can read.
Sorry...
- You think this is worth 1000 dollars do you?
- The Chronicel will consider it dirt cheap.
Packs everything, including a gun. Okay sister,
you've got yourself a deal.
Now let's take a look at the canidates. The one we
pick has got to be the typical average man. Typical,
American and can keep his mouth shut.
Show me an American who can keep his mouth shut,
and I'll eat him.
Okay Benny, bring them in, one at a time...
Did you write that letter to Miss Mitchell?
- No, I didn't.
- Why are you here then?
Well the paper said there was some jobs around.
Thought there might be one left over.
- Have any schooling?
- Yeah, a little.
- What do you do when you work?
- I used to pitch.
- Baseball?
- Yeah.
- Where'd you play?
- Bush leagues, mostly
- How about family? Got any family?
- No.
- Oh, just travelling through huh?
- Yeah, me and a friend of mine. He's outside.
- He looks all right.
- Oh, he's perfect and a baseball player What could
be more American?
- Wish he had a family though.
- Be less complicated without a family His face is
wonderful.
They'll believe him! Come on.
- What's your name?
- Willaby. John Willaby they called me in baseball.
Would you like to make some money?
- Yeah... maybe...
- Would you be willing to say you wrote that letter and
stick by it.
I get the idea. Yeah, maybe.
- That's our man, he's made to order.
- I don't know. He doesn't seem like the kind of guy
that will fall in line.
When you're desparate for money, you'll do a lot of
things Mr. Connell. He's our man, I tell you...
- He's fainted. Get some water, quickly
- Sit him up.
- You all right?
- Yeah, I'm all right.
How many is that, six?
Pretty hungry, weren't you?
- All this John Doe business is batty if you ask me.
- Well, nobody asked you.
Trying to improve the world by jumping of buildings.
You couldn't improve the world, if the buildings
jumped on you.
- Don't mind him, he hates people.
- He likes you well enough to stick around.
That's cause we both play doo-hickies.
I met him in a boxcar a couple of years ago. I was
fooling around with my harmonica and he comes over
and joins in. I haven't been able to shake him since.
- All right boys, here he is.
- No, no, no, you can't take pictures of him like that,
eating a sandwich and with a beard.
- But he's going to jump of a building.
- Yes, but not because he's out of a job. That's not
news. This man's going to jump as a matter of
principal.
- Maybe you're right.
- We'll clean him up, put him in a hotel under
bodyguards and make a mystery out of him.
- Did you speak to Mr. Norten?
- He thinks it's terrific. He says for us to go the limit.
Wants us to build a bonfire under every bigshot in the
state. Oh swell!
- Is that the contract?
- Yeah.
- What's he doing here?
- A friend of his, they play duets together
- Duets? But can we trust him?
- I trust him.
- Oh you trust him, well that's fine.
- I suppose he trusts you too. Oh stop it now He's all
right.
Okay, but we don't want any more than a couple on
this thing. Now the first thing I want is an exact copy
of the John Doe letter in your own handwriting.
- I've got it already here.
- That's fine. Now I want you to sign this agreement.
It gives us an exclusive story under your name, day
by day, from now until Christmas.
On December 26, you get one railroad ticket, out of
town.
And they agree to have your arm fixed. That's what
you want, isn't it? Yeah, but it's got to be by Bone,
Set or Brown.
Here sign it. Meanwhile, here is 50 dollars, spending
money.
That's fine. Benny, take charge of him. Get him a
suite at the lmperial and some bodyguards.
- He needs some new clothes Benny.
- Do you think we'd better have him de-loused?
- Both of them?
- Yes, both of them, but don't let them out of your
sight.
- Hey Benny, grey suit huh?
- Yeah.
Okay fellows...
Take it easy John Doe.
And you, start pounding that typewriter Oh boy this is
terrific. No responsibilites on our part, just statements
from John Doe and we can blast our heads of.
Before you pop your head off, don't forget to make
that check out for 1000.
You sit outside the door, to make sure no one comes
in. You two fellows sit in here.
Pretty nifty huh?
- He ain't going to get me to stay here.
- Sure you are.
No sir, that spot under the bridge, where we slept last
night, is good enough for me...
- Say, what do I do with this baggage?
- Stick them in the bedroom.
Give me mine, I ain't staying.
- You know we were headed for the Columbia River
Country before all this John Doe business came up,
don't you?
- Sure, I remember.
Say, did your ears pop coming up in the elevator?
Mine did.
Oh Long John, I tell you it's no good. You're going to
get used to a lot of stuf that's going to wreck you.
Why that 50 bucks in your pocket is beginning to
show up on you already...
- Stop worrying. I'm going to get my arm fixed out of
this.
- Hey, here are some cigars the boss sent us. Have
one.
- You?
- No.
Say I bet you the Major Leaguer's don't rate an outfit
like this.
- Here make yourself comfortable. Paper?
- I don't read no papers, and I don't listen to no radios
either.
I know the world has been shaved by a drunken
barber, and I don't have to read it.
I've seen guys like you go under before. Never had a
worry, then got a hold of some dough and went goofy.
- Hey did you get a load of the bedroom?
- No.
The first thing that happens to guys like that is he
wants to go into restaurants and sit down at a table
and eat salads and cupcakes and drink tea.
Boy what that kind of food does to your system.
The next thing the dope wants is a room. Yes sir, a
room with steam heat! And he can't sleep unless he
has a bed.
Hey stop worrying. Fifty bucks ain't going to ruin me.
I've seen plenty of fellows start out with 50 bucks and
wind up with a bank account.
- What's the matter with a bank account?
- Let me tell you Long John that when you become a
guy with a bank account...
...they got you! Yes sir, they've got you.
- Who's got him?
- The Heelots!
Hey there's the City Hall's tower I'm suppose to jump
off of. It's even higher than this.
- Who's got him?
- The Heelots!
Hey, wait a minute! You're not suppose to jump until
Christmas Eve. Do you want to get me into a jam?
If it's going to get you in a jam, I'll do you a favor I
won'tjump.
- And when they've got you, you've got no more
chance than a road-rabbit.
- Who'd you say was going to get him?
- Hey is this one of those places where you ring if you
want something?
- Yeah, just use the phone.
Boy, I've always wanted to do this.
Look Doc, give me that again, will you? Who's going
to get him?
- The Heelots. Who are they?
- Listen sucky, ever been broke?
Sure, mostly often.
All right you're walking alone. Nota nickle In your
jeans, you're asfree as the wind, nobody bothers you.
Hundreds of people pass you by in every line of
business. Shoes, hats, automobiles, furniture,
everything. And they're all nice lovable people.
And they let you alone, is that right?
Then you get a hold of some dough, and what
happens?
All those sweet, lovable people become Heelots!
A lot of heels. They begin creeping up on you, trying
to sell you something. They get long claws...
. then they get a strangle-hold on you. And you squirm
and you duck and you holler and you try to push them
away, but you haven't got a chance. They've got you!
First thing you know, you own things. A car for
instance. Now your whole life is messed up with a lot
more stuff.
You get license fees, and number plates, and gas, oil,
taxes, insurance...
...and identifcation cards, and letters and bills and then
flat tires, dents and trafic tickets and a million and
one other things.
And what happens?
You're not the free and happy guy you used to be.
You've got to have money to pay for all those things.
So you go after what the other fellow's got. And there
you are, you're a Heelot yourself.
- You win, here take the 50. Go on, get rid of it.
- You bet I will, just as fast as I can. I'm going to get
some canned goods, a fishing rod and the rest, I'm
going to give away.
- Give away?!
- Hey, get me a pitcher's glove. I've got to get me
some practice.
- Say, he's giving it away. I'm going to get me some of
that.
- Hey come back here, you Heelot.
Will you send up 5 hamburgers with all the trimmings,
5 chocolate ice-cream sodas, and 5 pieces of apple
pie?
- No, apple, with cheese. Yep, thanks.
Hello there!
- Well, well, if it isn't the man about town.
- All set Miss Anne.
Oh yes, let's go. Let's see, we want some action in
these pictures.
- Action?
- Yes.
No, no! This man is going to jump of a roof. Wait a
minute. Let me comb your hair.
Sit down.
There, that's better.
- You know, he's got a nice face, hasn't he?
- Yeah, he's pretty.
Here sit down. Quiet egg-head.
- All right, now a serious expression.
- Can't, I'm feeling too good.
Oh come on, this is serious. You're a man disgusted
with all of civilization...
- With all of it?
- Yes, you're sore at the world, come on now!
- Crabby guy huh?
- Yeah!
No, no!
No...
Now look, you don't have to smell the world.
- But all those guys in the pictures.
- Never mind those guys. All right, stand up.
- Now let's see what you look like, when you protest.
- Against what?
Against anything. Just protest.
You got me...
Look I'm the umpire. You just cut the heart of the
plate with your fast ball, and I called it a ball. What
would you do?
Why can't you call them right, you bone-headed...
I PROTEST!
AGAINST CORRUPTIOIN IN POLITICS
AGAINST COUNTRY HOSPITAL SHUTTING
DOORS TO NEEDY!
I don't care whose picture they're publishing. I still
say this John Doe person is a myth and you can
quote me on that.
And I'm going to insist on his being produced for
questioning. You know as well as I do, that this whole
thing is being engineered by a vicious man with a
vicious purpose Mr. D.B. Norten.
- Connell and Mitchell are at the house.
- Are they now? Come on.
Personally, I think it's just plain stupidity to drop it.
Now you should see his fan mail, thousands! This is
going over like a house on fire.
Personally, I think it's just plain stupidity to drop it.
Now you should see his fan mail, thousands! This is
going over like a house on fire.
- Why are you afraid of Connell? It's doubled our
circulation.
- Eah, but it's got everybody sore. Hands are bing
pulled. The Governor is starting a liable suit.
So let them see him. We'll go one better, they can
also hear him. You own a radio station Mr. Norten,
why not put him on the air?
Watch out for this dame D.B., she'll drive you batty
We can't let them get to this bush-league pitcher and
they start pumping him.
No telling what the screw-ball might do. I walk in
yesterday, and here he is standing on a table with a
fishing pole.'
- Ake my advice and get him out of town, before this
whole thing explodes in our faces.
- If you do that Mr. Norten, you're just as much of a
dumb-cluck as he is.
You've got yourself a meal-ticket and you hate to let
him go.
Sure he's a meal ticket and I admit it. But, it is also a
wind-fall for somebody like Mr. Norten who's trying to
crash National politics.
That's what you bought the newspaper for, isn't it?
You want to reach a lot of people, don't you? Put
John Doe on the air, and you can reach 130 million of
them.
He can say anything he wants, and they'll listen to
him. All right, we'll forget the Governor and the Mayor
and all the small-fry like that. This can arouse
National interest.
If he made a hit around here, he could do every other
place in the country And you'll be pulling the strings
Mr. Norten.
- Go down to the office and arrange for some radio
time.
- But D.B. You're not going to fall...
I want it as soon as possible.
Okay, I just came in to get warm myself. Come on,
let's go.
Now don't you go, I want to talk to you.
Sit down.
- So, this John Doe idea was yours huh?
- Yes.
- How much money do you get?
- 30 dollars.
- Hirty dollars... What are you after, I mean what do
you want? Ajournalistic career?
- Money!
Money, well I'm glad to hear somebody admit it.
Do you suppose you could write a radio speech for
that fellow and hold him to it?
- Oh, I'm sure I can. Do it and I'll give you 100 dollars
a week.
- 100 dollars?!
That's only the beginning. You play your cards right,
and you'll never have to worry about money again.
- Oh I knew it.
- Hello.
- Whenever there's a pretty woman around... my
nephew Ted Sheldon.
- How do you do?
- All right Casanova, I'll give you a break. See that
Miss Mitchell gets a car to take her home.
- Always reading my mind, aren't you?
- Thank you very much for everything.
Oh Miss Mitchell. I think from now on, you'd better
work directly with me.
Yes sir.
I thought you were asleep.
- Oh you little brats! .
- Come, come, come children. It's past your bedtime.
I'm done. I'll never get this speech right.
- Oh yes you willAnne dear, you're very clever.
- Yes, I know.
- What are you looking for?
- Your purse, I need 10 dollars.
- What for, I gave you 50 just the other day
- Yes I know dear, but Mrs. Burke had her baby
yesterday.
- And there wasn't a thing in the house.
- And the community lady came. And the 50 is all
gone. Who is the 10 for?
- Websters...
- Websters.
You remember those lovely people your father used to
take care of. I thought I would buy them some
groceries. Oh Anne dear, it's a shame those...
You're marvelous! You're just like father used to be.
Do you realize that a couple of weeks ago, we didn't
have enough to eat ourselves?
Yes I know dear, but these people are in such need.
If you are thinking of that 1000 dollars forget it. It's
practically gone. We owed everybody in town. None
you've just got to stop giving your money away
- Oh Anne... I'm sorry.
- Don't pay any attention to me.
Here I am with a great opportunity to get somewhere.
To give us security for once in our lives and here I'm
stuck. If I can put this over, your Mrs. Burke can have
6 babies.
- You mean this speech you're writing.
- Yeah, I don't know. I just can't seem to get it to gel.
I created somebody who's going to give up his life for
a principal. Hundreds of thousands of people are
going to listen to him over the radio. And unless he
says something that is sensational, well, it's just no
good.
Well honey, of course I don't know what kind of
speech you're tying to write, butjudging from the
samples I've read, I don't think anybody will listen.
What?
Darling, there's so many complaining political
speeches, people are tired of hearing of doom and
despair on a radio...
...lf you can have him say anything, why not have him
say something simple and real. Something with hope
in it.
If your father were alive, he'd know what to say.
Yeah, Father certainly would.
Wait a minute.
- That's your father's diary Anne
- Father's? I never knew he had a diary.
There's enough in it for 100 speeches. Things people
ought to hear now-a-days.
You be careful of it, won't you dear? It's always help
keep your father alive for me.
You bet I will Ma.
Wait a minute. John Doe don't want to sign no
autographs.
- What does he do all day?
- What does he do all day? He's writing all these
memories.
Sorry Eddie, you can't see Mr. Doe. He wants to be
alone. No, he just sits around all day and commutes
with himself.
I don't know how you're going to stand it around here
until after Christmas?
I bet you ain't heard a crying whistle in two weeks?
Strike!
I know why you are hanging around.
You're stuck on the girl.
That's all a guy needs, is to get hooked up with a
woman.
- What was that, a single?
- First baseman dropped the ball.
Butter-fingers!
If a guy has a woman on his hands, first thing you
know, his life is balled up with a lot more things...
Did you get him?
- You're out!
- Swell.
- What's this, the end of the eighth?
- Ninth!
Hey Benny, there's a couple of mugs from the
Chroncel snooping around out here...
Come on angel-face.
What's the score angel-face? Three to two.
- Hey you've got swell form there.
- You must have been a pretty good pitcher Pretty
good? I was just about ready for the Major League,
when I chipped a bone in my elbow
- I got it pitching a 19 inning game.
- 19?
There was a Major League scout there watching me
too. He came down, after the game, with a contract.
You know what? I couldn't lift my arm to sign it.
- I'll be Okay though, as soon as I get it fixed up.
- It's too bad.
- What do you mean too bad?
- Huh, or that's you'll never be able to play again.
- What are you talking about, I just told you I was...
- Well you know how they are in baseball. If a guy is
messed up in a racket...
- A racket? What do you mean?
- I was just thinking about this John Doe business.
As soon as it comes out that it was all a fake, you'll be
washed up in baseball, won't you?
Yeah...
I never thought about that.
And another thing. What about all the kids in the
country? Kids that idolize ball players. What are they
going to think about you?
Yeah, hey Colonel!
- Did you hear that?
- I've got to figure some way out of this thing.
Elevators are still running.
- I know one way you can do it.
- How?
Well when you get up there on the radio, all you've
got to do is say the whole thing is a frame-up. It'll
make you a hero, sure as you're born.
- Yeah but, how am I going to get my arm fixed?
- That's a cinch. I know someone who'll give you
5000 dollars,
- 5000 dollars?
- Yeah, 5000 dollars and he gets it right away
You don't have to wait until Christmas.
- Look out Long, they're closing in on you.
- Say, who's putting up this dough?
The fellow that runs the Chronicel.
Here's a speech you can make, and it's all written out
for you.
5000 dollars. Holy Mackeral, I can just see the
Heelots coming, the whole lot of them.
It's on the level.
- No I'm sorry. Tickets for the broadcast are all gone.
- Phone the Bulletin.
- Hello John, all set for the big night?
- Turn around.
- Big smile Mr. Doe.
- Hold still.
Okay that's enough, take them out.
Here's the speech. It's in caps and double spaced,
you won't have any trouble reading it. Not nervous,
are you?
- No!
- Of course not, he wouldn't be.
- Who?
- John Doe, the one in there.
- Don't let your knees rattle, it picks up on the mike.
- You don't need to be nervous John, all you need to
remember is be sincere.
- Take the phone Miss Mitchell. It's for you.
- Yes?
- Hello mother.
- Oh thank-you darling. Oh there he is, the poor dear
man.
- Have you got the speech I gave you?
- Yeah.
I'll give this money to the Colonel just as soon as you
get started. We'll have a car at the side entrance
waiting for you.
- How'd you get in here?
- Oh, I just came in to wish him luck.
Out. My mother wishes you luck too. John, when you
read that speech, please believe every word of it.
- He turned out to be a wonderful person John.
- Who?
John Doe, the one in the speech.
You know something? I've actually fallen in love with
him.
- All right, there he is
- Come on. What's the idea?
Not so much, that's it.
- This is not the time for cheap publicity Mr. Connell.
- Listen, if that guy lays an egg, I want to get
something out of it.
Okay, that's enough. Now everybody get out. Come
on.
- How're you doing?
- Okay Benny, bring him in.
- Here you are boss, just like you ordered.
- Symbols of little people. Okay get them up.
This is ridiculous Mr. Connell. Come on, give me a
chance. The man in on the air in a few minutes.
- Come on snucks, you'd better bail out.
- Say good-bye Mr. Doe.
- Better get ready, one minute to go.
- One minute to go and the score is nothing to nothing.
Please John, you won't let me down, will you?
Will you? Of course you won't. If you think of
yourself as the real John Doe... Listen...
Everything in that speech, are things a certain man
believed in. He was my father John, and when he
talked, people listened...
And they'll listen to you too. Funny you know what
my mother said the other night?
She said to look into your eyes, and I'd see father
there.
- Hey, what do you say?
- Okay, we're coming, come on.
Now listen John, you're a pitcher so get in there and
pitch.
Good luck!
Let him through.
- Hey, let's get out of here.
- There's a door right there. Hey, what are you doing
here?
- That's what I'd like to know.
- Come on out now.
- He's a friend of mine. Let him alone, he's all right.
I'll be right over there, pulling for you.
No John, over hrere...
Stand by...
Phone the Chronicel, tell them to start getting those
extras out.
Good evening ladies and gentlemen. This is Kevin
Fry speaking for the New Bulletin.
Tonight we give you something new and entirely
different. Standing beside me is the young man who
has declared publicly on Christmas Eve he intends to
commit suicide.
Giving as his reason and I quote: I protest against the
state of civilization, end quote.
Ladies and gentlemen, the New Bulletin takes
pleasure in presenting the man, who is fast becoming
the most talked up person in the whole
country... John Doe.
Ladies and Gentlemen.
I am the man you all know as John Doe. I took that
name, because it seems to describe...
. because it seems to describe the average man.
And that's me.
Well it was me, before I said I was going to jump of
the City Hall roof at midnight on Christmas Eve...
Now, I guess I'm not average anymore. Now, I'm
getting all sorts of attention, from big shots too.
- We've been double-crossed.
- . The Mayor and the Governor for instance.
- They don't like those articles
- I've been writing. You're an imposter young fellow
That's a pack of lies you are telling.
Who wrote that speech for you?
- Spencer...
- Ladies and Gentlemen, the disturbance you just
heard, was caused by someone in the audience who
tried to heckle Mr. Doe.
The speech will continue.
People like the Governor and that fellow there, can
stop worrying. I'm not going to talk about them, I'm
going to talk about us.
The average guys. The John Does. If anybody
should ask you what the average John Doe is like,
you couldn't tell him, because he is a million and one
things.
He's Mr. Big and Mr. Small. He's simple and he's
wise. He's honest, but he has a streak of arsonary in
his heart.
He seldom walks up to a public telephone, without
shoving his finger into the slot to see if somebody left
a nickle there.
He's the man the ads are written for. He's the fellow
everybody sells things to. He's Joe Doks, the world's
greatest stooge and the world's greatest strength...
He's the man the ads are written for. He's the fellow
everybody sells things to. He's Joe Doks, the world's
greatest stooge and the world's greatest strength...
We're a great family, us John Does. We are the meek
who are suppose to inherit the earth.
You'll find us everywhere. We raise the crops, we dig
the mines, work the factories, keep the books, fly the
planes, and drive the buses.
When a cop yells stand back there you, he means us,
the John Doe's.
What kind of speech is that? Didn't you read it?
We've existed since time began. We built the
pyramids. We saw Christ curcified, pulled the oars for
Roman Empires, sailed the boats for Columbus.
Retreated from Moscow with Napeleon, and froze
with Washington at Valley Forge. We've been in
there, dodging left hooks since before history began
to walk. In our struggle for freedom, we've hit the
canvass many a time, but you always bounce back,
cause we're the people.
There's been a lot of talk about free people going soft,
that we can't take it. That's a lot of hooey!
A free people can beat the world at anything, from war
to tiddlely-winks, if we all pull in the same direction.
I know a lot of you are saying: What can I do? I'm
just a little punk, I don't count.
You're dead wrong. The little punks have always
counted, because in the long run, because the
character of our country is the sum total of the
character of its little punks...
But we've all got to get in there and pitch. We can't
win if we don't have the old teamwork and that's
where every John Doe comes in.
It's up to him to get together with his teammate. And
your teammate, my friends, is the guy next door to
you!
Your neighbor, he's a terribly important guy that guy
next door. You're going to need him and he's going to
need you, so look him up.
If he's sick, call on him, if he's hungry, feed him. If
he's out of a job, find him one.
To most of you, your neighbor is a stranger. A guy
with a barking dog and a high fence around him.
Now you can't be a strangerto any guy that is on your
own team.
Tear down the fence that separates you. Tear down
the fence and you tear down a lot of hates and
prejudices. Tear all the fences down in the country
and you'll really have teamwork.
I know a lot of you are saying to yourselves: He's
asking for a miracle to happen. He's expecting
people to change all of a sudden.
Well, you're wrong. It's no miracle because I see it
happen once a year.
And so do you, at Christmas time.
There's something swell about the spirit of Christmas,
to see what it does to people. All kinds of people...
Now why can't that spirit, that same warm Christmas
spirit, last all year round?
If each and every John Doe would make that spirit
last 365 days of the year,
we'd develop such a strength, we'd create a tidal
wave go good, that no human force could stand
against it
Yes my friends. The meek can only inherit the earth,
when the John Doe's start loving their neighbors.
You'd better start right now Don't wait until the game
is called on account of darkness.
Wake up John Doe, you're the hope of the world.
John, you were wonderful.
- Let's get out of here.
- Now, you're talking.
I knew you'd wake up sooner or later. Boy am I glad
we got out of that mess.
462. I had the 5000 bucks sewed up. I could have
been on my way to Doc Brown.
You're a pitcher John. Now go in there and pitch.
What a sucker...
She's a Heelot, just like the rest of them. Lucky you
got away from her.
What was I doing up there making a speech anyway?
Me huh? The more I think about it, the more I...
Tear down all the fences? Why if you tore one picket
off, he'd sue you.
5000 bucks, had it right in my hand.
What do you mean he ran away? Well go after him,
find him. That man is terrific.
Here we come!
Jitterbug!
- How much money have we got left?
- A little bit.
- Better make it doughnuts huh?
- Yeah
What'll it be gents?
- Have you got a couple of steaks, about that big and
about that thick?
- And with hash brown potatoes, and tomatoes and...
. and doughnuts, yeah, I know Hey Mark, seekers.
On its way.
Hey, look! Join the John Doe club.
John Doe Club?
- You John Doe?
- Who?
- John Doe!
- Ah, you need glasses buddy
- Well, it's the spitting image of John Doe.
- Yeah, well his name is Willaby
- John Willaby. I'm a baseball player.
- I'd know that voice anywhere. You can't kid me.
- You're John Doe.
- John Doe?!
- Sitting right there! .
- You mean he's alive?
John Doe. Right there.
Hey operator, tell everybody in town, John Doe was
just in my place.
Yeah, he ordered doughnuts.
- What did John Doe look like, Mr. Mayor?
- He's one of those outdoor-type men.
No, you can't see him, cause you didn't vote for me
last time. Shame on you!
Has Mr. Norten come yet? He should have been here
15 minutes ago. There he comes now.
Now everybody, on your dignity Don't do anything to
disgrace the little town.
- Better let me talk to him.
- But present it to him as a great cause for the
common man.
Here he comes.
How do you do Mr. Norten. I'm the Mayor.
Let me go, you darn fool, I'm the Mayor! Mr. Norten!
- I'm the Mayor. Your office told me to hold him.
- That's fine, how is he?
Oh he's fine. He's right in my office there. It's an
honor having John Doe here.
The folks are so excited and proud. Call the paper
and tell them Mr. Norten is here.
Right inside Mr. Norten. My office, very comfortable
Mr. Norten. I just had it air-conditioned.
Gang way. Here he is Mr. Norten, well taken care of...
Hello John...
Mr. Mayor, if you don't mind, we'd like to talk to him
alone.
Certainly, certainly, all right everybody, clear out.
Don't argue with me here, wait until we get home.
Don't you push me around like that, even though I am
your wife.
Look Mr. Norten, I think you have a lot of nerve,
having those people hold us here...
- There's nobody holding you here Mr. Doe.
- Well, if there's no one holding us here, let's get
going.
- Incidently, my name isn't Doe, it's Willaby.
- Look John, something terribly important has
happened.
- They are forming John Doe clubs.
- We know of eight all ready and they say... John
Doe clubs? Why?
To carry out the principals you talked about in your
radio speech.
I don't care what they're forming. I'm on my way and I
don't care for being stopped.
But you don't know how big this thing is. You should
see the thousands of telegrams we've received and
what they're saying about you.
Look it started as a cirruculation stunt, didn't it? Well
you got your cirrculation, so why don't you leave me
alone.
Oh it started as a cirrculation stunt, but it isn't
anymore. Mr. Norten wants to back it, and start John
Doe clubs all over the country He wants to send you
on a lecture tour.
- Me?
- With your ability to influence people, it might grow
into a glorious movement.
Say, let's get something straight here. I don't want
any part of this. If you've got some idea that I'm going
around to lecture people, why you're crazy
Baseball is my racket, and I'm sticking to it.
- Come on Colonel,
- Please, please, I just got rid of one crowd.
Please Mr. Mayor, tell him the John Doe club wants to
talk to him
- Let them in Mr. Mayor, let them come in.
- Okay folks, but remember your manners, no
stampedeing. Walk slow, like you do when you come
to pay your taxes.
- Give me a chance.
- Come right in.
My name is Bert Hansen Mr. Doe. I'm the head soda-
jerkeratthe drug store.
Well sir, me and the wife heard your broadcast and
we got quite a bang out of it, especially my wife.
Kept me up half the night saying: That man's right
honey. The trouble with the world is nobody gives a
hoot about his neighbor.
And that's why everybody is sore and cranky to each
other in town. I kept saying that's fine, but how does
a guy go around loving the kind of neighbors we've
got?
Old Sourpuss for instance...
See Sourpuss Smithers is a guy lives all alone next
door to us. He's a cranky old man, runs a second-
hand furniture store. We haven't spoken to him for
years.
I always figured he was an ornery old gent, who hated
the world cause he was always slamming his garage
door and playing the radio so loud, he kept half the
neighbors up.
Well next morning, I'm out watering the lawn, and
there is old Sourpuss on the other side of the hedge,
straightening out a dent in his fender
My wife yells to me out the window. Go on, speak to
him Bert.
I yelled over to him Good-morning Mr. Smithers. He
went right on pounding his fender...
Was I burnt. So I turned around to give my wife a
dirty look and she said louder, louder, he didn't hear
you.
So in a voice that you could have heard in the next
county, I yelled, Good morning Mr. Smithers...
Well sir, you could have knocked me over with a
feather. Old Sourpuss turns around, surprised like and
puts on a big smile, came over and took my hand like
an old lodge brother and he said, good-morning
Hansen.
I've been wanting to talk to you for years, but I
thought you didn't like me, and then he started
chatting away
...like a happy little kid. Well, before we were through,
I found out Mr. Smithers is a swell egg, only he's
pretty deaf.
And he says it's a shame, what little we know about
our neighbors, and then he got an idea and says...
...how about inviting everybody some place where we
can all get together and get to know each other a little
better?
I'm feeling so good by this time, I'm right for anything,
so, Smithers goes around the neighborhood, inviting
everybody to a meeting at the schoolhouse.
And I tell everybody that comes in the store, including
my boss...
Oh, I'm talking too much.
No, no, tell more.
Over 40 people showed up. None of us knew what to
do, but we sure got a kick out of seeing how glad
everybody was and to say hello to one another.
- Oh yeah, we made Mr. Smithers Chairman.
- And we decided to call ourselves the John Doe club.
Oh incidently, this is my wife. Come here honey.
- This is my wife Mr. Doe.
- How do you do Mr. Doe?
- This is Sourpuss, or excuse me, Mr. Smithers, Mr.
Doe.
- That's all right, if you didn't call me Sourpuss, it
wouldn't feel natural.
I guess everybody in the neighborhood came except
for the Laneys.
The Laneys live in a big house, with an iron fence
around it and they always keep their blinds drawn.
We always figured he was just an old miser, always
keeping his blinds drawn, so why bother inviting him?
Until the milkman spoke up and said, say you've got
the Laney's all wrong. And then he tells us how they
cancelled their milk last week.
And when he found a note in the bottle, he got kind of
curious and peeked in under the blind and found the
house was empty...
If you ask me, he says, they're starving.
Old man Laney has been bringing his furniture over to
my place at night. One piece at a time and selling it.
Half a dozen of us ran over there to fetch him and we
brought him to the meeting.
What a reception they got. Everybody shook hands
with them and made a fuss over them and well finally
Mr. And Mrs. Laney just sat down and cried...
- And then we started finding out about a lot of other
people.
- You know Grouble for instance.
- Grouble is here.
- Yeah, for sure.
Of course you don't know Grouble, but...
He's a man that everybody figured was the worse no-
account in the neighborhood. He was living like a
hermit.
Nobody would have anything to do with him. That is
until the postman told us the truth.
Grouble he says, lives out of garbage cans, because
he won't take charity.
- Just like you said on the radio Mr. Doe.
- About a dozen families got together and gave
Grouble a job, watering their lawns. Isn't that
wonderful.
And then we found jobs for 6 other people and they've
all gone off relief.
- And my boss found a job for old-man Laney
- And he gave you that 5 dollar raise.
Yeah, ain't that swell.
- Well Bert, I feel slighted. I would like to join, but
nobody asked me.
- I'm sorry Mr. Mayor, but we voted no politician could
join.
Just the John Doe's of the neighborhood, cause you
know how politicians are.
The reason we wanted to tell you this Mr. Doe was to
give you an idea of what you started. And from where
I'm standing, I don't see any sense in seeing you
jumping off any building.
No...
Well, thank-you for listening. Good-bye Mr Doe.
You're a wonderful man.
It strikes me that you can be mighty useful, walking
around for a while.
Good-bye.
I'm Mrs. Laney, Mr. Doe. May god bless you my boy.
I'm all mixed up.
I dont' get it...
All those swell people think I'm going to jump of a
building or something. I've never had any such idea.
A man would have to be a mighty fine example
himself, if he were going around telling other people...
Say, what happened here the other night, was on
account of Miss Mitchell. She wrote the stuf.
Don't you see what a wonderful thing this could be?
But we need you John.
You're hooked. I can see that right now Well, I'm
through.
For three years, I've been trying to get you up to the
Columbia River Country, first it was your glass arm,
then it was something else, now it's the John Doe
club. Well, I ain't waiting another minute.
Gang way you Heelots!
Colonel wait a minute. Colonel!!
Now I want you to go along with John Doe and Miss
Mitchell to handle the press and the radio.
- Me?
- Yes, I don't want to take any chances.
- And Johnson.
- Yes D.B.
Your crew will do the mop-up job. They'll follow John
Doe into every town and see that the clubs are
properly organized and the charters issued.
There are only 8 flags up there now, and I want to see
that map covered before we are through.
This has been growing like wildfire. If they had been
making demands, I would understand it, but the John
Does ask for nothing.
People are going off relief. If this keeps up, I'll be out
of a job.
As soon as he gets strong enough, we'll find out what
John Doe wants. 30 every Thursday, 60 at 60! Who
knows what!
I'm sorry boss, they just won't let anyone talk politics
to them. It's crazy!
We've got to get to him. He represents millions of
voters.
I tell you ladies and gentlemen, this has been nothing
short of a prairie fire. We've received so many
charters to the John Doe club, that we haven't been
able to take care of them.
I don't need to have that many pins stuck in me.
This John Doe convention is a natural. It's going to
put our city on the map...
Why over 2400 John Doe clubls are sending
delegates. Can you imagine that?
You, Mr. Mayor, will be the official host. You will make
the arrangements for decorating the city the parade,
and the reception for John Doe when he gets home...
- And don't wear your high hat...
- No high hat?
No. And from you Connell, I want a special John Doe
edition everyday until the convention is over.
And now if you will please, step into the outer ofice
and look your prettiest, because there are
photographers there to take pictures of this
committee.
Don't worry D.B. Everything will be taken care of.
- Well I don't get it.
- Get what?
This John Doe has cost you a fortune. Now this
convention is going to cost plenty
- Well?
- Well, I'm stuck with 2 and 2 and I'm a sucker if I can
make 4 out of it.
Where do you come in?
I have the satisfaction of knowing, that my money has
been spent for a worthy cause.
I say, I'd better stick to running the paper huh?
I think maybe you'd better.
And Connell. I'd have the John Doe contract, and all
the receipts and the money we advanced him and the
letter from Miss Mitchell that I gave 1000 dollars for.
Yes... sure.
- Well, we leave for the airport in half an hour
- Is that Johnny boy's room, I'd better hustle him up.
He'll be ready on time, he's packing.
- Did you see his picture on the cover ofTime?
- Yeah.
I've got to give you credit Annie Girl, I've handled
some big promotions in my time, everything from a
World's Fair to a channel swimmer, but this one
certainly got me spinning.
And now a John Doe convention.
If you could only get him to jump ofthe City Hall roof
on Christmas Eve, I'd guarantee you half a million
people there.
- Charlie... what do you make of him?
- Who, Johnny Boy?
I don't know what angle you want, but I'll give you a
quick...
Number one, he's got great yokel appeal, but he's a
nice guy. Number two, he really beginning to believe
that he wrote that suicide letter that you made up...
- Number three, he thinks that you're Joan ofArc or
something.
- Yeah, I know.
Number four, well you know what number four is.
He's nuts about you. Yeah, it's running out of his
ears.
You left out number five. We're all heels, me
especially.
Come in.
- I'm all packed.
- Good! I'll go and get Benny boy
Okay Charlie boy.
- Can I help you pack?
- No thank-you.
- Do you care if I sit down, out here.
- No.
I had a crazy dream last night...
- It was about you.
- About me?
It sure was crazy. I dreamt I was your father.
There was something I was trying to stop you from
doing.
So I got up out of bed, and I walked right through the
wall here, straight to your bed.
You know how dreams are... and there you were in
bed.
But you were a little girl, you know, about 10 and very
pretty too.
So I shook you and as soon as you opened your
eyes, you hopped out of bed and started running like
the devil in your nightgown, and you ran right out the
window there and you ran over roofs of buildings for
miles...
And i was chasing you.
And all the time you were running, you kept growing
bigger and bigger and pretty soon you were as big as
you are now.
You know, grown up.
And all the time I kept asking myself, what am I
chasing her for?
And I didn't know. Isn't that an odd one?
Well, anyway you ran into some place and I ran in
after you. When I got there, there you were, getting
married.
The nightgown had changed into a beautiful wedding
gown.
You sure looked pretty too.
And then I knew what it was I was trying to stop you
from doing.
Dreams are sure crazy, aren't they?
Would you like to know who it was, you were
marrying?
A tall, handsome man I suppose...
It was that fellow that sends you flowers everyday
What's his name? Mr. Norten's nephew.
- Sheldon...
- Yes, him.
But here's the funniest part of it all...
I was the fellow up there doing the marrying. You
know, the Justice of the Peace or something.
- Were you? I thought that you were chasing me?
- Yes, I was, but I was your father then, you see.
But the real me John Doe, well that is, Long John
Willaby, I was the fellow up there with the book.
- Do you know what I mean?
- Guess so, then what happened?
Well, I took you across my knee, and I started
spanking you. That is I didn't do it, I mean I did do it
but, it wasn't me see, I was your father then.
I put you across my knee and said, Annie, I won't
allow you to marry a man that is just rich or has a
secretary that sends you flowers...
The man that you marry has got to swim rivers for
you, he's got to climb high mountains for you, he's got
to...
And all the time, the guy up there with the book, just
stood there nodding his head and he said...
Good Pop. Whack her one from me, cause that's just
the way I feel about it too.
He said, come on down here and whack her yourself.
So I came down and I whacked you a good one.
So he whacked you and then I whacked you another
one then we were both whacking you...
Well if you're through whacking her, come on, let's get
going. Okay fellows, right in here...
- Hej Benny.
- When's our plane take off again?
A couple of minutes.
How many people do you think we've talked to
already? Outside the radio I mean.
- I don't know. About 300,000.
- 300.000.
What makes them come Anne. What makes them
listen and then set up their John Doe clubs.
I've been trying to figure it out...
What we're handing them is a platter It's been heard
a milllion times. Love thy neighbor, clouds of silver
linings, turn the other cheek...
I've heard it a million times too, but... There you are.
Maybe they're like me. Just beginning to get an idea
of what those things mean.
I never really thoughtabout people before. They were
justsomebody to fill up the bleachers.
The only time I worried about them, was when they
didn't come in to see me pitch.
Lately, I've been watching them when I talk to them. I
can see something in their faces.
I can feel that they are hungry for something.
Do you know what I mean. Maybe that's why they
came. Maybe they're just lonely and wanted
somebody to say hello to them...
I know how they feel. I've been lonely and hungry for
something practically all my life.
All aboard folks.
- Somebody else sitting here?
- No, no, no, that's your seat.
- And this is your coat.
- Mine?
A little token of appreciation.
It's beautiful D.B. I don't know what to say
Well don't say anything. Just sit down.
Go ahead, open it, open it.
- Oh, it's lovely.
- And a new contract goes with it.
Well, come on, spring it. You've got something on
your mind. Must be stupendous...
That's what I like about her. Right to the point, like
that!
All right PracticalAnnie, here it is. Tomorrow night,
before a crowd of 15,000 people, I'm talking a nation
wide radio hook-up, John Doe will annouce the
formation of a third party.
All right PracticalAnnie, here it is. Tomorrow night,
before a crowd of 15,000 people, I'm talking a nation
wide radio hook-up, John Doe will annouce the
formation of a third party.
- A third party?
- Yes, the John Doe party.
Devoted to the interests of all the John Doe's all over
the country.
Which practically means 90% of the voters. He will
also announce the candicy of the third party for
President.
A man whom he personally recommends. A great
humanitarium. The best friend the John Doe's have.
- Mr. D.B. Norten...
- Yes.
Though the opening of the convention is hours away
the delegates are pouring into the ball park by the
droves.
These John Does are the people that have been
laughed at and ridiculed, but here they are...
gay and happy, having travelled thousands of
miles... Their expenses paid by their neighbors, who
have come here to pay homage to their hero, John
Doe.
It's a simple idea that can sweep the country...
An idea based on friendliness, on giving and not
taking. On helping your neighbor and expecting
nothing in return.
And if a thing like this can happen, don't let any of
your grumbling friends tell you that humanity is falling
apart.
This is John B. Hues signing of now and returning
you to our main studio, until 9 o'clock, when the
convention will officially open.
John! Come in.
- Say I'm kind of... it's raining out a little.
- That's all right. It's good to see you.
- Sit down.
Thanks.
- It's forAnne.
- Oh how nice! Thank-you very much.
- I'm terribly sorry she isn't here.
- She isn't?
No she just left. I'm surprised you didn't run into her
She went over to Mr. Norten's house.
Did you want to see her about something important?
Yeah, well no, it will wait.
He's a nice man, Mr. Norten I mean. He's done an
awful lot for...
My coat is pretty wet. I'm afraid I may have wet the
couch a little.
- Well, I guess I'll see her at the convention later.
- Yes of course, I'll see that she gets the flowers.
- Good night Mrs. Mitchell.
- Good-night John.
Mrs. Mitchell.
I'm kind of glad thatAnne isn't here.
I came over here hoping to see her alone. Kind of
hoping I wouldn't too, you know
There was something I wanted to talk to her about.
It can wait, I guess.
- Good-night...
- Goodnight John.
Say Mrs. Mitchell, have you ever been married?
I'm sure you have. That's pretty silly...
I guess you must think I'm kind of batty...
I guess I'd better be going.
John...
John, my husband said, I love you, will you marry
me?
He did?
- What happened?
- I married him.
That's what I mean, see? It was as easy as all that?
You see, I love Anne, and it's going to be awfully hard
for me to say it...
She's so wonderful and all I ever was, was a bush-
league pitcher.
I think she is in love with another man. The one she
made up. You know, the real John Doe.
That's pretty tough competition. He would know what
to say. I get up to it, around it and back of it, but I
never know what to say.
You know what I mean. So, the only chance I've got,
is if somebody could kind of give her a warning. Sort
of prepare her for the shock.
- You mean you would like me to do it?
- Yeah, I was thinking, sort of break the ice.
Of course I will John...
Thank-you Mrs. Mitchell. You're Okay.
This John Doe meeting is going to be one of the
biggest things that ever happened! They're coming
from all over, trains, boxcars, wagons...
- Have you had your dinner yet?
- Not yet.
- Go ahead and have your dinner.
- Wait a minute John.
- How are you Mr. Connell.
- Hello John. John I want to have a little talk with you.
What's the matter? Are you fallilng, come here.
Did you read that speech that you are going to read
tonight?
No I never read the speeches before I make them. I
get more of a kick out of it that way.
Just exactly what I thought. Benny go down to the
office and tell them to give you the speech. There's a
copy on my desk.
- You know Mr. Norten told me not to leave him, not
even for a minute.
- Go and get it, we'll be at Jim's bar up the street.
You're a nice guy John. I like you.
You're gentle. I've always liked gentle people. Me,
I'm hard.
Yep, I'm hard, but you want to know something? I've
got a weakness. Never guess that, would you?
Well, I have. Want to know what it is?
Star Spangled Banner. Screwy huh?
Maybe it is, but play the Star Spangled Banner and
I'm a sucker for it.
Always gets me right here. You know what I mean?
- Yeah, gets me right back here.
- Oh, back there huh?
Well, every man to his own taste.
You weren't old enough for the World War, were you
John?
No of course not. You must have been just a kid.
I was. I was young and raring to go.
Know what my old man did when I joined up? He
joined up too.
Got to be a Sgt. And here's the kick for you. We were
in the same outfit.
Funny huh?
He was killed John. I saw him die.
I was right there and I saw it with my own eyes.
Me, I came out without a scratch.
Except for my ulcers...
I should be drinking milk you know This stuff is
poison.
Tommy?
What do you say huh?
Yep, I'm a sucker for this country I'm a sucker for the
Star Spangled Banner and I'm a sucker for this
country.
I like what we got here. I like it.
A guy can say what he wants and do what he wants,
without having a baonet shoved in his belly
- And that's all right, isn't it?
- You bet ya!
- And we don't want anybody coming around and
changing that do we?
- No sir!
When they do, I get mad. I get boiling mad.
Right now John, I'm sizzling.
I get mad for a lot of other guys, besides myself...
I get mad for a guy named Washington, and a guy
named Jeffereson and Lincoln.
Lighthouses John. Lighthouses in a foggy world.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah, you bet.
- Listen pal. That fifth column stuf was pretty rotten,
isn't it?
- Yeah, it certainly is.
And you'd feel an awful sucker if you found yourself
marching right in the middle of it, wouldn't you?
You wouldn't know, cause you're gentle, but that's
what you're doing.
You're mixed up with skunk!
A no-good dangerous skunk!
- Say, you're not talking about Mr. Norten, are you?
- I'm not talking about his grandfather's pet poodle.
- You must be wrong Mr. Connell. He's been
marvelous about the John Doe clubs.
- You're really sold on this John Doe idea, aren't you?
- Sure.
Yes sir, I don't blame you, so am I. It's a beautiful
miracle.
A miracle that could only happen right here, in the
good old U.S.A.
I think it's terrific. What do you think about that? Me,
hard-boiled Connell and I think it's terrific.
Now suppose an unmentionable worm, whose initials
are D.B., was trying to use that to shove his way into
the White House?
So he could put the screws on. So he could turn out
those lights in the lighthouses.
- What would you say about that huh?
- They can't use the John Doe clubs for politics.
- That's the whole idea.
- Is that so? Then what's a big political boss like
Haman doing here in town?
And a labour leader like Bennet, and a lot of other big
shots up at D.B.'s house right now
Wolves! Wolves John, waiting to cut up the John
Does...
- Wait til you get a gander at that speech you are
going to make tonight
- Miss Mitchell writes those speeches, and nobody
can make her write that kind of stuf.
They can't huh? Who do you think writes them? My
Aunt Emma?
I know she writes them and gets a big bonus for
writing them too.
799. A mink coat and a diamond bracelet. Don't write
them!
A mink coat and a diamond bracelet. Don't write
Why that gold-grabbing dame would double-cross her
own mother for a handful of Chinese yen!
- Lf you weren't drunk, I would...
- Hey boss!
- Here's the speech boss.
- Go on and read it John and then start socking.
Hey wait a minute Mr. Doe.
Tommy, you'd better bring me a glass of milk.
I'm smoking too much.
Yes Charlie. Got everything all set? Got John Doe
taken care of?
How many people do you think will be there? 15,000!
Oh, that's fine.
Listen Charlie, as soon as John Doe stops talking
about me, I want you to start that demonstration.
Don't worry about that D.B. My boys are there.
They'll take care of it.
Yes, I'll be there 15 minutes after I get your call.
- Why Mr. Doe.
- Where are they?
They're in the dining room sir.
Well gentlemen, I think we are ready to throw that
great, big bombshell.
A conservative estimate says that we will get
anywhere between 15 and 20 million John Doe votes
Add to that, the labor board Mr. Bennet will throw in...
...nothing can stop us.
As I said before, I am with you, providing that you can
guarantee the John Doe vote.
You can count on me, on one condition. Bennet has
to be taken care of.
Didn't I tell you everybody in this room will be taken
care of. My agreement with you gentlemen stands!
I'm with you D.B., but I still think it's a very daring
thing we're attempting.
These are daring times. We are coming to a new
order of things. There's too much talk going on in this
country.
Too many concessions have been made. What the
people need is an iron-hand.
Discipline!
May I offer a little toast to Miss Anne Mitchell. The
beautiful and brilliant lady who is responsible for all
this.
Mr. Norten I would like to talk to you alone for a
minute.
- Miss Mitchell has something to say to us.
- Say it!
Hello...
John I'm so glad to see you. I was terribly worried.
- Did you write this?
- Yes I did John, but I had no idea what was going on.
- You didn't?
- No.
That's a swell bracelet you're wearing.
John, why aren't you at the convention?
- Is there anything wrong?
- No, no nothing is wrong. Everything is fine.
So there's going to be a new order of things huh?
Everybody's going to cut himself a nice fat slice of the
John Does huh?
You forgot one detail, Mr. Bigshot. You forgot me.
The prize stooge of the world.
Why you or anybody else thinks he's going to use the
John Doe clubs for his own rotten purpose, he's going
to have to do it over my dead body.
Now hold on a minute young man. That's rather big
talk. I started the John Doe clubs with my money
- And I'll decide whether or not they are being properly
used.
- No you won't. You're through deciding anything.
And what's more, I'm going down to that convention
and I'm going to tell those people exactly what you
and all your fine-feathered friends here are trying to
cook up for them.
And I'm going to say it in my own words this time!
Wait a minute fellow. My Uncle wants to talk to you.
Now listen to me my son. Before you lose your head
completely...
may I remind you that I picked you up out of the gutter
and I can throw you right back there again!
You got a nerve accusing people of things. These
gentlemen and I know what's best for the John Does
of America, regardless of what tramps like you think!
Get off that righteous horse of yours, and come to
your senses. You're the fake. We believe what we
are doing.
You're the one that was paid the 30 pieces of silver.
Have you forgotten that? Well, I haven't.
You're a fake John Doe, and I can prove it.
You're the big hero that is suppose to jump of
buildings and things.
Do you remember? What do you think your precious
John Does will think, when they find out that you had
no intention of doing it?
That you were being paid to say so. You'd be lucky
they don't run you out of the country
With the newspapers and radio stations that these
gentlemen control,
we can kill the John Doe movement deader than a
doornail and we'll do it too, the minute you step out of
line.
Now if you still want to go to that convention and
shoot your trap off, you go ahead and do it.
You mean to tell me, that you would kill the John Doe
movement if you can't use it for what you want?
You bet your bottom dollar we would!
Well that certainly is a new low
I guess I've seen everything now.
You sit there smoking your big cigars, and think of
deliberatly killilng an idea that has made millions of
people a little bit happier.
An idea that has brought thousands of them here from
all over the country. By bus, by freight and jalopys...
So they could pass on to each other, their own simple
little experiences.
I'm just a mug and I know it. But I'm beginning to
understand a lot of things.
Why your types are as old as history If you can't lay
your dirty fingers on a decent idea, and turn it and
squeeze it...
...and put it into your own pocket, you slap it down!
Like dogs! If you can't eat something you bury it!
Why this is the one worth while thing that has come
along. People are finally finding out that the guy next
door isn't the bad egg.
Simple isn't it? And a thing like that has got a chance
of spreading until it touches every dog-gone human
being in the world.
And you talk about killing it. Or when this fire dies
down, what's going to be left?
More misery, more hunger and more hate. And
what's to prevent that from starting all over again?!
No one knows the answer to that one. And certainly
not you, with the slimy ideas you've got.
The John Doe idea may be the answer though.
Yet you sit on your fat hulks and tell me kill it if you
can't use it.
You go ahead and try. You couldn't do it in a milion
years with all your radio stations and all your power...
because it's bigger than whether I'm a fake, it's bigger
than your ambitions and it's bigger than all the
bracelets and fur coats in the world.
- You bet it is John!
- And that's exactly what I am going down there to tell
those people!
Why you ungrateful rat. My Uncle has been too good
to you.
He's getting away.
John...
I tried to warn you D.B. You played with dynomite.
Don't let him get away!
I'll stop hlm cold. Don'tworry, I've been ready forthisl
John! Oh John please listen to me. I didn't know
what they were going to do. Let me go with you
John...
Go ahead driver.
Mr. Norten wants to see you.
Listen to me Mayor and you do what I say. I want
them both arrested.
You tell the police to pick up Connell, I've got the girl
here. I don't care what you charge them with, but
keep them in jail overnight.
Hello Bulletin, put your editor on.
Three cheers for John Doe!
- Ladies and Gentlemen.
- One moment John. We'll begin with a prayer.
Quiet please.
Ladies and gentlemen, let us have a moment of silent
prayer for the John Does all over the world.
Many of whom are homeless and hungry
Quiet please. Everybody rise.
Newsboys, hundreds of newsboys are swarming into
the stadium.
Yelling John Doe is a fake.
An investigation by the Chamber of Commerce.
Must be some kind of a gag.
Come on, come on, step on it.
You all know your places, so let's get going.
- Will you autograph my balloon?
- Sure.
Ladies and gentlemen. This is exactly what I came
down here to tell you about.
Please, if you just be quiet for a few minutes, I can
explain the whole thing.
As you know, this paper is published by D.B. Norten.
Wait a minute. Wait a minute everybody.
My name is D.B. Norten. You all know me.
I accuse this man of being a faker. We've been taken
for suckers and I'm the biggest of the lot.
I spent a fortune backing this man, in what I believed
to be a sincere and worthy cause, just as you all did...
And now I find out it nothing but a cheap racket.
Cooked up by him and two of my employees.
For the sole purpose of collecting dues from the John
Does all over the country.
- That's a lie!
- It's not a lie. Nickles and dimes being stufed into
thier own pockets. You can read all about it in the
newspapers.
- That's a lie!...
- This man had no intention ofjumping of the top of a
building.
- He was paid to say so. Do you deny that?
- That's got nothing to do with it.
- Were you paid for it, or weren't you?
- Yes, I was paid, but...
- And what about the sucide note? You didn't write
that either.
- What difference does that make?
- Did you write it or didn't you?
- No I didn't write it.
You look in your papers Ladies and Gentlemen, and
you'll find Miss Mitchell's signed confessioin that she's
the one that wrote it.
- Listen folks, it's true that I didn't write the letter, but.
- See, he even admits he didn't write it. You're a fake
John Doe.
And for what you've done to all these good people,
they ought to run you out of the country and I hope
they do it.
Speak up John. We believe you.
Listen folks. Now that he's finished shooting off, I've
got a few things to tell you.
Get him out of here.
I'm sorry folks, but we can't hear him anymore. There
is something wrong with the loud-speakers.
- John Doe's a fake! Booooooo!
- Please, they can't hear me.
This thing is not working. Ladies and Gentlemen.
This thing is bigger than whether I'm a fake...
You believe me?
Sure I believe you. Walking my legs off, picking up
5000 signatures for a phony.
Well here you are Mr. Doe. 5000 names asking you
not to jump off any roof.
- It makes no difference! The idea is still good.
- We don't have to give up our club. Yeah, well you
can have it.
They're starting to throw things. Someone is going to
get hurt and I'm afraid it will be John Doe.
- Listen to that crowd!
- I've got to go there.
- Sorry lady, orders.
Please let me go. They are crucifying him. I can help
him!
- We've got orders to hold you.
- Orders from who? Can't you see it's a frame-up?
Oh mother, they won't let me go, they won't let me go.
Listen to me. You've got to listen to me.
Back to the jungle, you hobo!
- Trust a low-racket?
- Why shoud we do that?
Stick to your clubs? The idea is still good.
Believe me folks!
Listen, John Doe is the only hope for the world.
They managed to get him out of the park. If that boy
isn't hurt, it's a miracle!
This certainly looks like the end of the John Doe
movement.
Well boys, you can chalk up another one to the
Pontius Pilots.
I should have been there. I could have helped him.
He was so all alone.
A lot of us are going to be mighty ashamed of
ourselves after tonight. We certainly didn't give that
man much of a chance.
- Would you like some more coffee Long John?
- No thanks Colonel.
John Doe Proven Faker!
Liar! Cheat! Lmposter! Why don't you jump? Cause
it ain't midnight...
Good-bye Mr. Doe. You're a wonderful man!
You are a wonderful man Mr. Doe
Now get in there and pitch.
FAKE!
You're a fake John Doe and I can prove it. You're the
hero that's suppose to jump of tall buildings and
things.
What do you think your precious John Does will think,
when they find out that you had no intention of doing
it?
- That you were paid for the whole thing?
- Christmas Eve at midnight.
- Silent Night.
- Holy Night...
- John Doe? Is that screwball still around?
- Yeah, that dame has been calling all day
- Sure, sure, at midnight huh?
We'll have the place surrounded with nets.
They're laughing at me.
You're a sick girlAnne. You'd better take it easy.
Who are you calling now? You called that number,
not more than 10 minutes ago.
- Hello Mr. Connell, have you seen him yet?
- Now listen Anne, he can't possibly get in without our
seeing him...
I'm watching the side door and the Colonel is out
front, so stop worrying.
Thank-you.
Ann! Don't be foolish.
If this isn't the craziest, the battiest, the looniest, wild
goose chase I've ever heard of.
- Oh shut up Bert,
- Sourpuss is right. Well if he is, I'm a banana split.
That man is going to be on that roof. Don't ask me
how I know, I just know and you know it as well as I
do!
Sure, sure, I'd like to believe in fairy tales, but the guy
is a fake and he isn't going to jump of any roof.
I don't think he was any fake, not with that face!
Anyway, what he stood for wasn't a fake.
Okay honey, Okay.
The elavators ain't running. Colonel! You shouldn't
have gotten out of bed Miss.
- Has he been here.
- Have you seen him? Nope, haven't seen him for a
week.
- Where's Connell?
- He's watching the other door.
You're swell.
No sense in going up there. I've been here for hours
and he ain't here.
Let me go!
Now that's crazy. It's 14 floors.
This is as far as the elavator goes. We have to walk
up to the tower.
That crank is probably full of Christmas cheer and is
asleep in some flop-house.
Let's go, I've got to decorate my tree.
Well I give up. I don't know what gave us the idea
that he would attempt anything like this.
I guess you're right. I guess the jokes on us. Let's
go!
I hope nobody finds out we've been here.
I wouldn't do that if I were you John.
It'll do you now good. The Mayor has policemen
downstairs.
With instructions to remove all marks of identification
that you may have on your person.
You'll be buried in Potter's Field, and you will have
accomplished nothing.
I've taken care of that. I've already mailed a copy of
this letter to Mr. Connell.
- John why don't you forget this foolishness. Stop
right where you are Mr. Norten, if you don't want to go
over with me.
I'm glad you gentlemen are here.
You killed the John Doe movement all right. But
you're going to see it born all over again.
Now take a good look Mr. Norten.
John...
John... Oh John... I won't let you do it. I love you!
Please don't give up. We'll start all over again...
Just you and I. It isn't too late. The John Doe
movement isn't dead yet.
You see it isn't dead, or they wouldn't be here. It's
alive in me!
They kept it alive by being up here!
Darling! It should have been killed but it wasn't. We
can start clean now.
Just you and I. It'll grow lt'll grow big John, cause it
will be honest and kind.
Oh John, if it's worth dying for, it's worth living for.
Oh please John!
John look at me. You want to be honest don't you?
You don't have to die to keep the John Doe idea alive.
Someone already died for that one.
The first John Doe. And he's kept that idea alive for
nearly 2000 years!
It was He who kept it alive in them and He'll go on
keeping it alive in them.
For every John Doe movement these men kill, a new
one will be born.
Oh don't you see darling? This is no time to give up!
You and I John, we... Oh no, no John!
If you die, I want to die too.
I love you!
Mr. Doe... you don't have to... We're with you Mr.
Doe...
- We just lost our heads, and acted like a mob...
- What Bert's trying to say is, we need you Mr. Doe.
There was a lot of us who didn't believe what that
man said. We were going to start up our John Doe
club again.
Whether we saw you or not. And there are a lot of
others who are going to do the same thing...
- Mr. Sourpuss even got a letter from cousin inToledo
and...
- Got it right here Mr. Doe.
Only it would be a lot easier with you.
Please come with us Mr. Doe.
John! Mr. Doe... she's Okay.
We'll take her down to the car.
They you are Norten, the people! Try and lick that!